so I wanted to do a video on heart
symptoms that you may not be aware of
because most people think about heart
problems of having chest pain okay or
left arm pain or left shoulder pain or
pain and left jaw or even cold sweats so
most people know these right here but
they might not be aware of other
symptoms okay that relate to heart
problems and I'm talking about a deeper
problem with the heart that could
involve the artery becoming clogged the
heart muscle becoming very rigid and
losing its elasticity or maybe the
ventricle which is the pump becoming
dilated enlarged or the entire heart
becoming enlarged so all of those
symptoms could create these known
symptoms but let's talk about the ones
that very few people make the connection
number one chronic coughing while you're
laying down okay that potentially could
be a symptom of an underlying heart
problem now also realize that this could
be a calcium deficiency as well or some
type of weakness within your immune
system it could be a virus so it's not
necessarily always a heart but it could
be especially if you have the majority
of these symptoms right here
nausea this could come from a lot of
things it could be your gall bladder
your digestion your stomach but it
potentially could relate to a
cardiovascular situation swelling in
your lower legs or ankles especially on
the left side because the heart is on
the left side if you have more swelling
on the right side that potentially could
be more reliever related what's
happening is the heart is losing its
function as a pump and fluid is backing
up in the lower part of the body next
one is pitting edema which relates to
this right here so when you press into
the lower part of your leg or the ankle
it leaves a dent into the tissue so
that's fluid backing up into the tissues
all right next thing is fainting okay
that's one lack of energy upon exertion
so you start to exercise and you just
don't have the energy so that could be
that you're really really out of shape
or potentially could be the heart next
one heavy legs when you're climbing
stairs are going up an incline now that
could be an adrenal issue as well or it
could be the heart but realize that the
adrenals back up the heart also the
other one is just you're out of breath
when climbing stairs or going up an
incline so that's another common heart
symptom and last one ascites okay that's
a situation where you have this
protruding belly which is fluid leaking
from the liver but that fluid in the
belly could put a lot of pressure up to
the organs to affect the heart it looks
like fat but it's mainly fluid and you
usually see this scenario with the
skinny guy on the beach with a potbelly
that could potentially be ascites but it
could also be fat too so it's not always
that situation all right now that you
have the complete picture on some
symptoms related to the heart what
should you do about it I think one of
the most important tests that you should
get is a coronary artery calcification
test there's some other names for it but
this test measures the amount of calcium
in the coronary artery around the heart
and it's one of the best predictors of
mortality from heart attacks you want
this score to be zero okay some other
things and nutrients that I highly
recommend you want to be on vitamin k2
vitamin k2 keeps the calcium out of the
arteries and in the bone where it
belongs and k2 also works with vitamin
d3 these two together are a really good
combination the next most important
vitamin is vitamin E I don't recommend
getting a typical synthetic vitamin E
get a high-quality combination between
two coffe Rawls and tocotrienols get the
whole thing and start taking that
vitamin E is one of the most important
vitamins for the heart it'll protect the
inside of the arteries from oxidation
because it's an antioxidant and it will
also increase the levels of oxygen in
the heart muscle tissue preventing
scarring and fibrosis of the heart
tissue and that
helps make your muscles a lot stronger
too so you'll notice when you take it
you're just gonna feel stronger and
there's some interesting Studies on how
this can reduce the symptoms of heart
problems especially in China which is
chest pain the foods that are high in
vitamin E are the leafy greens and nuts
and seeds number three you need to get
off carbs immediately the carbs are
clogging the artery and they're creating
the problem because it spikes insulin
not to mention filling your liver with
fat which then puts more pressure on the
heart so you need to be on a healthy
keto diet without any question if you if
you don't know what I'm talking about I
put a link down below on what to do
number for fasting vitally important to
reduce inflammation and also give into
ketosis so your heart especially if it's
damaged would prefer ketones as their
main fuel source so when you fast and
get off carbs you increase ketones it
wouldn't hurt to take some NZT oil which
also will turn into ketones and feed the
heart and also by the way the feeds the
brain as well and go for long walks on a
kind of a flat surface because what you
want to do is you want to keep your
stress low but you want to get a lot of
oxygen into the heart into the tissues
you can even do hyperbaric oxygen
therapy which is another great thing to
infuse these cells with a super amount
of oxygen because what someone with a
damaged heart has is hypoxia which is a
lowered amount of oxygen in the tissues
because of damage if you want more
information about this CAC test I put a
link right here